anyway another major event this weekend  the first ever champions of Dancing with  the Stars juniors and only et on lines  lauren zima join the winners from t  valley what do you guys feel the first  ever winners of the show I feel amazing  and oh we all win it ten year old  dancing queen Skye brown full of  inspiration to the very end sometimes  girls are too afraid to do things or  like the they don't know if they can do  it or not but I just gotta say he can do  anything  she's like the most expiring person I've  ever met in my life and so happy that  were such good friends now but get this  Skye and her team had to keep their big  win  top secret after taping the finale  nearly four months ago that was the hard  just tell me you thought a big deal I  just tell me when you got cut and I was  like nope I'm not telling you gonna have  to watch to find out okay I'm not  feeling the teeth spilling anything  [Applause]  [Music]